[Musique]
Philippe Dixier, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle Serview. On
vous reçoit dans le cadre de votre
projet d'un dirigeable solaire
révolutionnaire avec un profil qui est
breufté made in France par vos soins.
Vous vous en êtes l'inventeur avec votre
vos équipes. Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire ?
C'est un effet indirigeable tout à fait
inédit, solaire hein comme vous l'avez
dit. Euh et aussi effectivement un
dirigeable tout temps. Tout temps. Euh
c'est un dirigeable qui marche quand on
a envie de s'en servir ce qui n'est pas
le cas de tous les dirigeables
historiques. Le la grande question des
dirigeables depuis toujours, c'est que
quand on a envie de s'en servir une fois
sur deux au dernier moment, l'opérateur
vous dit "Non, ça sera pas possible, le
vent est trop fort, c'est pas bon, et
cetera, c'est reporté." Bon, c'est
insupportable hein d'avoir comme ça des
machines qui volent une fois sur deux.
Donc ce problème-là a été pris à part le
corps par beaucoup de gens dans le monde
et nous nous avons une solution
originale effectivement pour rendre ce
dirigeable opérationnel tout en au moins
90 % du temps hein. Ce 10 % d'annulation
c'est quelque chose d'acceptable 50 %
c'est pas acceptable.
Donc tout temps, on peut partir par gros
temps. Euh parlez-nous un peu de son
profil avec effet Ventury qui permet
Oui, c'est très technique. Vous
m'excuserez à ce moment-là de descendre
quand même dans des explications
techniques. Euh qu'est-ce que c'est le
l'astuce ? Ça consiste à changer la
force du dirigeable. Voici Voici le
dirigeable classique, il a une forme de
révolution allongée parce que
bien stable bien stable qu'on voit la
camé stable qu'on le voit. Voilà, je
vous le montre. Voilà, vous le voyez. Il
a une forme blonde comme un ballon de
rugby très allogé. Tous les dirigeables
ont cette forme là. Mais celui-là, il a
une particularité par rapport aux
autres, c'est qu'il a un fond plat. Vous
voyez ici, il a un fond plat. C'est tout
bête. Et ben, c'est magique. C'est
magique parce que tous les dirigeables
quand ils atterrissent et quand ils sont
dans le vent, le vent les soulève, les
balotte et ils arrivent pas à se poser.
Il faut des gens pour tirer sur des
élingues, pour le le maîtriser et
l'arrimer. Avec ce fond plat, il se
produit un phénomène physique tout à
fait naturel. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a un
effet venturique qui se produit entre le
fond du dirigeable et le sol et qui fait
que le dirigeable est plaqué au sol.
C'est le vent qui pose le dirigeable. Et
du coup, le pilote n'a besoin de
personne au sol et il va pouvoir se
poser, s'arrimer tout seul et descendre
de sa machine après l'avoir arrimé.
Il va s'arrimer si si mes souvenirs sont
bons. Vous avez un pieu télescopique à
l'avant.
Oui, à l'avant, il y a un pivot
absolument. Il va s'arrimer en un point
et quand il sera plaqué au sol, il va
rester plaqué au sol. Bien, si le vent
tourne, il va rester dans le lit du
vent. il va pivoter pour rester dans le
lit au vent parce que il ne supporterait
pas d'avoir un vent de travers, ça le
casserait. Il faut qu'il reste dans le
lit du vent. Donc le vent va le faire
tourner comme un bateau à l'encre qui va
rester dans le lit du vent. Et donc
comme ça il a besoin effectivement d'un
certain espace pour pour tourner au sol.
Mais en dehors de ça, il y a pas besoin
de plus d'infrastructure qu'un pivot et
un terrain suffisamment grand pour qu'
il soit libre de tourner au sol. Donc
les capteurs solaires seront sur le le
dessus de l'enveloppe.
Oui, dans un premier temps, ils seront
plutôt à l'arrière. D'ailleurs, ils
seront plutôt à l'arrière pour le
démonstrateur et puis si le client en
veut plus, effectivement, on en mettra
sur le dessus, sur les côtés
suffisamment pour que le dirigeant
puisse capter l'énergie dont il aura
besoin pour avancer par rapport à l'air.
Quelle autonomie, quelle capacité de
charge, quelle capacité d'emport, quel
facteur de charge on peut lui imposer ?
L'autonomie là, je vais déranger
certaines personnes, l'autonomie, elle
est illimitée. Elle est illimitée. Il y
a pas de limite. La seule limite
d'emploi, c'est le vent trop fort. Et
ça, on gère. Mais en tant que capacité,
je dirais de voler en l'air, c'est
illimité. On peut faire le tour du
monde, aucun problème. On va faire le
tour du monde d'ailleurs.
Quel quel Alors, on parle devant puis
après on va on va s'arrêter des au
niveau des questions techniques.
Le maximum de vent, ça supporte des
rafales à combien ?
Maximum devant pour pouvoir opérer et se
poser. Pic devant maximum 50 km/h. Ce
qui fait que 9 jours sur 10, on opérera
même plus que ça hein. Maximum devant en
l'air. Euh
non.
Est-ce est-ce qu'on peut rentrer dans un
cyclone avec votre aéronef ? Oui,
complètement. Complètement même. Et
c'est même ce qu'on va faire parce que
en fait quand vous parlez de vitesse
d'un dirigeable ou d'un avion, vous
parlez le plus souvent d'une vitesse par
rapport au sol. Mais on est dans l'air,
donc on est entraîné par la masse d'air.
Et donc pour rentrer dans un cyclone ou
une tornade, en fait, il suffit de
rester immobile avec cette machine qui
flotte toute seule, elle reste en l'air
et vous restez dans l'air, vous êtes
balloté par l'air, vous êtes dans
l'ouragan à 200 km/h, mais vous vous
rendez pas compte que vous avancez à 200
km/h, vous êtes porté par l'air et vous
vous n'êtes pas agressé par la masse des
ranges. Vous êtes vous êtes en en
apesanteur dans l'air et vous êtes
toujours manœuvrant. C'est-à-dire que
vous avez vos hélices qui vont vous
permettre d'évoluer quand même de bouger
par rapport à la masse d'air mais sans
violence. Vous êtes entraîné par l'air.
On parle un peu de sécurité. On a tous
cette vieille idée de du vieux zéplin
de Indenburg
du pardon dubourg. Exactement. Qui
s'enflamme. Oui, il s'enflamme. Oui.
Est-ce que le vote il s'enflamme ?
Non.
Pourquoi il s'enflamme pas ?
Il est gonflé à l'hélium donc il
s'enflamme pas.
Mais quand bien même il serait gonflé à
l'hydrogène parce que s'il était pas
habité, il y aurait pas de raison de ne
pas le gonfler à l'hydrogène. Bon euh
bon aujourd'hui on s'est parfaitement
géré si vous voulez le le
l'inflammabilité de l'hydrogène.
Bon
deux petites questions de l'internet,
nous sommes en direct. Quit de la
durabilité de l'engin
avec les matériaux qu'on utilise, c'est
quelques années.
C'est quoi quelques années ? Bon euh 3
ans, 5 ans, après ça tout dépend de ce
que veut le client. Euh
3 ans, la durabilité, c'est-à-dire ça,
on recharge l'hélium tous les 3 ans, on
re Ah non, non, non. La durabilité des
matériaux fixes, c'est-à-dire la toile,
les sacs d'hélium, toutes ces choses-là.
Oui, c'est de 3 ans comme les voiles de
bateau si vous voulez à peu près.
Une révision tous les 3 ans, c'est ça ?
Voilà. Bon, tous les ans, c'est imposé
par la réglementation mais ça sera pas
forcément nécessaire mais enfin c'est de
l'ordre de plusieurs années. Par contre,
l'hélium, vous posez la question. Oui.
Alors là, ça c'est un vrai sujet, hein,
parce que les réservoirs d'hélium qui
est là-dedans, les sacs d'hélium euh ils
ont beau être de la meilleure technique
actuellement disponible, il ont fait des
choses merveilleuses, il y a toujours
des fuites. Il y a toujours des fuites.
L'hélium est la plus petite molécule de
de l'univers. Elle passe à travers tout,
même à travers l'acier, même à travers
le verre. Donc il y a toujours un peu de
fuite. Donc au bout d'un certain temps,
vous avez perdu du gaz porteur. Donc il
faut recharger. Et euh ça alors par
contre c'est avec ça ça sera plutôt de
l'ordre de quelques semaines. Au bout de
quelques semaines, il faudra recharger
sauf
une petite recharge quoi.
Oui, une petite recharge mais il faut
revenir à terre. Alors ça c'est l'état
de l'art actuel mais nous développons
avec air liquide, c'est pas un secret,
euh le moyen de régénérer du gaz porteur
en vol. C'est-à-dire que tout en volant,
on va réinjecter du gaz porteur dans
dans les réservoirs pour compenser les
fuites. Comment fait-on ? C'est très
simple. dans la dans l'air, dans
l'atmosphère dans l'atmosphère vous avez
de l'oxygène, vous avez de l'azote et
vous avez un gaz dont on parle moins qui
est la vapeur d'eau. C'est de la vapeur
d'eau. La vapeur d'eau, il y en a pas
beaucoup mais il y en a toujours.
Quelque fois la voyez, c'est les nuages
et le plus souvent vous la voyez pas
parce que elle est sèche, c'est-à-dire
qu'elle est invisible mais elle est
toujours là. Et donc en mettant une
paroie froide, en refroidissant une
paroie avec des procédés très simples,
on va condenser la vapeur. Donc on va
récupérer de l'eau et cette eau, on va
l'électrolyer parce qu'on a de
l'électricité à l'énergie. on
vaélectrolyer, on va en tirer O2 H2 de
l'hydrogène. Et cette hydrogène, on va
la réinjecter dans les réservoirs en vol
pour compenser les fuites. Et ainsi, on
a une autonomie en gaz porteur
illimitée.
Vitesse de croisière
toujours faible avec les dirigeables.
On prend son temps.
Voilà, on prend son temps, on gère hein,
on gère l'énergie disponible. Si on veut
aller vite, ça consomme beaucoup trop de
puissance et on y arrive pas parce que
l'énergie disponible qu'on peut
recharger avec l'énergie solaire est pas
suffisante. Donc il faut apprendre à
être patient. C'est une école de
patience. Mais une chose qui est sûre,
c'est qu'on va toujours au bout. On va
toujours au point. Ça prendra beaucoup
de temps, mais on ira toujours.
Autre petite question de l'internet qui
n'est peut-être pas dans votre secteur
d'activité. Existe-t-il des méthodes
d'extraction de l'hélium ?
Ah, alors là, j'aurais du mal à vous
répondre. L'hélium, l'hélium est un gaz
naturel. qu'on ne sait pas produire. Il
est présent à la surface de la Terre,
hein, par l'histoire géologique de la
Terre. Il est présent dans les
réservoirs de pétrole ou de gaz naturel.
il y en a toujours un petit peu. On le
récupère et on en fait cet usage. Il y a
d'autres usages mais on ne peut pas le
fabriquer. C'est un élément naturel
qu'on peut pas fabriquer. Donc
voilà, les réserves d'héliumées.
Alors
capacité d'emport,
cette machine là que je vous montre,
quelle taille elle fait au
elle fait 50 m de long. 50 m de long.
50 m de long, 12 m de long.
Poid total.
Le poids total au décollage est de 1300
kg et la charge utile est de 450 kg.
C'est-à-dire à peu près 5 personnes. On
va mettre cinq personnes à l'avant hein.
Et avec ça, un poids total au décollage
2800 kg.
Ça fait vachement grand pour 5
personnes.
Mais ça c'est toutes les machines
aérostatiques. Vous saz il y a une loi
que on n'est pas prêt de de
transgresser, c'est que pour lever 1 kg,
il faut 1 m³ de gaz porteur, 1 m³
d'hélium ou 1 m³ d'hydrogène. Ça c'est
incontournable. Donc si la machine pèse
au décollage 1800 kg, il faut 1800 m³.
D'où son volume et d'où sa grande
surface. Donc c'est le seul inconvénient
des machines aérostatiques
ou un avantage ou un avantage dans le
sens où ça consomme pas beaucoup
d'énergie. On est
alors j'ai bien dit que le volume
pouvait être considéré comme un
inconvénient. Ça n'appelait pas vraiment
un mais on peut penser que effectivement
c'est un inconvénient mais par ailleurs,
il y a que des avantages. Que des
avantages parce que cette machine si
vous voulez elle reste en l'air sans
consommer d'énergie. Elle n'a pas besoin
de puissance pour rester en l'air. Alors
que les avions, les hélicoptères pour
rester en l'air, il faut qu'ils aient
une puissance minimum, hein. Il
consomment de l'énergie rien qu'en
restant en l'air. Ce n'est pas le cas
des aro des des aérostates d'une façon
générale. Ballon au dirigeable. On va on
va on continue les questions de
l'internet parce que elles sont
pertinentes. Joujou pour milliardaire
point d'interrogation
pour tout le monde.
Pour tout le monde.
Pour tout le monde. Cette machine en
prix en prix commercialisé en série si
vous voulez c'est une machine qui
coûtera moins d'un million. Moins d'un
million d'euros pour 5 personnes.
Oui.
Alors, remplaçant des bateaux cargo.
Point d'interrogation. Le futur
remplaçant des bateaux cargo.
Je ne pense pas parce que les bateaux
cargo, si vous voulez, ils prennent des
charges monstrueuses, hein. Vous pouvez
transporter des milliers de tonnes avec
des cargos. Bon, pour transporter des
milliers de tonnes avec cette machine,
c'est théoriquement possible mais c'est
quand même plus facile de le faire avec
des cargos. Je ne crois pas beaucoup au
transport de charge lourde avec des
dirigeables. Bien que ce soit
transport de passagers
de passagers mais on ne concurrencera
jamais les Boeing sur Paris New York.
Non non, c'est le transport de
proximité, accès à des lieux difficiles,
grande souplesse d'emploi mais pas de
concurrence envers les bateaux de
transport ou avec les avions de de
Est-ce que ça fait du bruit ?
Zéro.
Zéro bruit.
À 100 m, vous l'entendez pas ? Vous le
voyez mais vous ne l'entendez pas. Il
fait moins de bruit qu'un votre
lave-vaisselle. Vous l'entendez pas ?
On a fait un peu de veille sur votre
projet depuis un certain nombre d'années
parce queon vous connaît depuis un
certain nombre d'années. un projet qui
nous intéresse beaucoup, surtout le
profil Ventury et euh comment la
concurrence, on a vu l'armée américaine
s'intéresser à ça, on a vu Google
s'intéresser à ça d'une façon très
effective
mais pas du tout avec le même profil de
Alors, si vous voulez aujourd'hui euh il
y a une vingtaine de projets innovants
dans le monde hein, de projets de
dirigeable très innovants pour pour
lever ce verrou technique dont on a
parlé au début, c'est-à-dire
l'indisponibilité du dirigeable, le
manque de de de fiabilité, le manque de
maniabilité. Il y a une vingtaine de
projets en moyenne. Mais sur ces 20
projets dans le monde, il faut savoir
qu'il y en a 10 qui sont français. C'est
la France qui fait la course en tête.
Est-ce que la France investit dans ces
dans ces projets ?
Pas beaucoup. Vous savez, les porteurs
de projet généralement, ils ont pas
beaucoup d'argent. Les investisseurs,
ils connaissent pas les porteurs de
projet. Là, il y a un problème de mise
en relation.
Le président il vous aide un peu au
Macron ? Je sais pas s'il pense à ça. On
n pas eu l'occasion de lui poser la
question. On pose plutôt la question si
vous voulez avec des instances qui
s'appellent les pôles de compétitivité
et qui sont chargés de on va dire de
d'aider à l'émergence de ces projets
innovants. On est on est actuellement en
discussion avec eux. J'espère que on va
trouver enfin la solution pour financer
ce projet. Quelques millions d'euros
faut-il pour
quelques millions de combien ? 10 15.
Non non non non. entre 2 et 4 millions
d'euros suivant ce qu'on va mettre à
bord et tout ça, mais c'est l'ordre de
grandeur. C'est ça. C'est entre 2 et 4
millions d'euros pour faire voler cette
machine et que tout le monde comprenne,
voit concrètement les avantages
fantastiques qu'elle apporte.
Il y a des millions et des millions
d'euros de dollars qui sont investis
chez Google par l'armée américaine.
L'armée américaine, si mes souvenirs
sont bons, essaie de faire un un drone
dirigeable.
Vous en avez entendu parler, vous pouvez
nous en dire quelques mots avec votre
regard de professionnel.
Les projets de dirigeable sont pas trop
sur la place publique.
Ah benah, il y en a plein sur internet
hein.
Non, il y a des images de synthèse qui
n'est pas tout à fait la même chose.
Quand l'armée a des projets comme ça, en
général, elle en parle peu. Bon, il y a
des projets de de de dirigeable pour les
militaires aux États-Unis. Oui. Oui, il
y a quelques projets effectivement. Bon
euh bah c'est des projets concurrents
parce que on ne prétend pas avoir le
monopole de la bonne idée hein. Il y a
d'autres d'autres voies techniques qui
permettent de lever ce verrou dont je
vous ai parlé. Il y en a au moins trois
autres. Et en fait il y a une
compétition entre les porteurs de projet
hein pour être celui qui va enfin
démontrer qu'on a fait sauter ce verrou
qui bloque le marché.
Vous vous êtes le seul à avoir ce profil
de dirigeable. Non non non non. Il y a
quatre autres projets dans le monde qui
ont ce qui utilisent ce fond plat. Il y
a un projet russe, il y a un projet euh
portugais, euh il y a un projet anglais
qui utilise le fond plat. Oui.
Une question de l'internet. Combien de
temps pour un Paris-Marse environ ?
Par v nul. Euh, on va prendre cette
hypothèse, par vent nul, par bon
ensoleillement, par bon ensoleillement,
vous pourrez faire le trajet à 35 ou 40
km/h, c'est-à-dire que vous allez mettre
20h. Voyez, c'est lent. C'est toujours
lent.
On va pas concurrencer le TGV. Non,
le TGV non
non, c'est pas de ce côté-là. Non, non,
c'est pas de ce côté-là qu'il faut
chercher. Pas du tout.
Votre équipe est et vous êtes vous êtes
combien sur ce projet
? Actuellement, on est quatre.
On était six cet été. Là, on est quatre
permanents. Oui.
Depuis combien de temps vous avez cette
idée de de faire des dirigeables ?
Ah,
revenez revenez à à l'essence même à la
genèse de de cette idée. Ça ça vous est
apparu comme ça dans un rêve ?
comment c'est apparu. J'ai un
grand-père, j'avais un grand-père parce
qu'il nous a quitté qui était un
pionnier des dirigeables à la belle
époque des dirigeable, c'est-à-dire en
19 dans les années 1900. Et je l'ai
connu et il me racontait tout ça. Moi,
j'étais fasciné. Ça intéressait pas
grand monde dans ma famille mais moi ça
m'intéressait beaucoup. Et à 10 ans,
j'ai décidé qu'on pouvait prendre des
décisions à 10 ans. J'ai décidé quand je
serais grand, je serai pilote de
dirigeable. Alors, j'ai voulu faire
super-héros pour apprendre à faire des
dirigeables. Je suis arrivé à
super-héros et j'ai dit je veux suivre
les cours de dirigeable. À ce moment-là,
on regardez, il y a pas de cours de
dirigeable, c'est fini. Il y a longtemps
qu'on fait plus de dirigeable. C'était
une grosse déception. Donc j'ai fait ma
carrière dans l'industrie et puis quand
j'ai pris ma retraite, je me suis dit
maintenant je vais revenir à mon projet
de dirigeable. Et c'est seulement donc
en 2008
2009 que je me suis mis sérieux. J'ai
sérieusement à à travailler là-dessus.
J'ai créé la société DIY Solar en 2009
et depuis donc 2009, nous travaillons à
concevoir et réaliser ce cet appareil.
Vous avez fait des essais, un
prototypage ? Racontez-nous tout.
Ah si je vous raconte tout, ça va être
très long. Mais pour l'essentiel, temps
hein,
pour l'essentiel, nous avons fait un
commencé par faire un modèle réduit avec
ce fameux fond plat.
Il y a une vidéo d'ailleurs qui est
disponible sur votre chaîne YouTube.
Voilà. Elle est disponible effectivement
sur notre chaîne
chaîne YouTube Diris Solar.
Tout à fait.
Euh cette vidéo, si vous voulez tout le
monde peut la voir. En fait, ça n'est
jamais qu'un extrait de ce qu'on a fait.
On n pas tout expliqué mais ce qu'il
faut comprendre que cette formule du
fond plat qui étonné tout le monde au
départ, elle a été parfaitement
démontrée avec ses premiers essais sur
modèle réduit. On a on a mis tout
simplement un ventilateur pour créer un
vent et on a fait évoluer le cette ce ce
démonstrateur dans ce courant d'air et
on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement quand il
arrive près du sol dans le vent, tout
d'un coup, il est aspiré. Bon, après ça,
quand on est passé, je dirais à l'étude
de du modèle grandeur nature, on a fait
un certain nombre de simulations.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons des logiciel
extrêmement puissant qui permettent de
simuler ça parfaitement, hein, des
logiciels qu'on appelle CFD. Euh, et on
retrouve exactement cet effet. Tout ceci
est parfaitement
vérifié si vous voulez par tous les
logiciels disponibles. cet effet magique
du fond plat, on le retrouve
parfaitement et et c'est bien et
maintenant donc ce qu'il faut c'est en
effet construire le l'appareil grandeur
nature pour que tout le monde constate
au besoin en montant à bord hein que ce
dispositif cette forme tout à fait
originale aide complètement le
dirigeable à atterrir et résout le
problème finalement de l'indisponibilité
et manque de maniabilité du dirigeable.
Alors question d'internet qui va
utiliser ça ? Première question.
Deuxième question. Au vu de l'espace
utilisé de sa capacité d'emport, de
transport, pardon, cinq personnes
ne serait-ce pas réservé à une certaine
élite ?
Pas du tout. Ça va être le grand public
parce que la première cible pour cette
machine, la première cible commerciale,
c'est le tourisme, ce qu'on appelle le
tourisme de proximité. Et premier site
visé, le Mont-Saint-Michel. Au
Mont-Sain-Michel, vous avez 3 millions
de visiteurs par an. On a fait une
enquête de marché sur la DIC du
Mont-Sain-Michel. Questionnez les gens,
dites donc il y a un projet comme ça,
une machine qui pourrait vous emmener
autour du mont, vous montrer le mont
tout toutes ses faces, 20 minutes de
vol, vous voyez tout ça, vous revenez.
Est-ce que vous êtes partant pour entre
70 et 100 € ? 70 % des gens questionnés
en
personne
Oui. Oui. 70 % des gens interrogés ont
répondu "Mais on y va, c'est
fantastique. On y va, ça sera
extraordinaire." C'est c'est le même
prix si mes souvenirs sont bons qu'un
baptême du LM autour du
Montsaint-Michel.
Oui, à peu près.
Qu'on a déjà fait. C'est magnifique.
Par contre, c'est très bruyant.
C'est bruyant. C'est très rapide. On va
on avance tout ça avec ça. C'est c'est
silencieux. Ça vibre pas. C'est super.
On peut s'arrêter en vol.
Ça dérange pas la faude.
Ça dérange pas la faude. Ça dérange pas
les touristes.
C'est c'est silencieux. C'est magnifique
à voir. Ça flotte dans l'air. Et donc au
Mont-Sain-Michel pour répondre à la
demande qu'on a ainsi calibré, il
faudrait 200 dirigeables comme ça autour
du monde. Impensable bien sûr. le nombre
de sites touristiques existant dans le
monde où des touristes seraient prêts à
utiliser cette machine pour mieux voir
parce que quand on mon rêve faire ça le
tajemal
volvicomtte Versailles les falaises des
tretat
les plages du débarquement on a
identifié des centaines de sites dans le
monde où les gens seraient ravis de
pouvoir s'élever et aller regarder ça
tranquillement d'en haut sans nuisance
sans bruit
prendre des photos.
Est-ce que Est-ce que mis à part
l'industrie touristique
Oui, il y a d'autres applications.
Je vous écoute
bien entendu. Euh aujourd'hui, si vous
voulez euh il y a un énorme besoin de
capture de données de tout genre sur la
nature. Ça l'air des big data. On a des
appareils pour capter ces données, pour
euh traiter ces données, pour prendre
des décisions, faire des analyses,
prendre des décisions. Prenez en
agriculture par exemple, prenez le cas
de l'agriculture est très intéressant.
Dans les vignes, il y a des maladies.
Alors aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'on fait
? Alors, on arrose de de de produits
divers sans savoir si à cet endroit-là,
il y en a vraiment besoin ou pas. Euh si
on pouvait monter en haut, prendre des
vues, analyser très précisément ce qu'on
voit, on verrait par exemple, par
exemple, je prends cet exemple-là, la
flavescence dorée qui est une maladie
terrible qui naît quelque part dans la
vigne sur un pied de vigne et qui si on
les éradique pas très vite, elle va se
propager.
On peut faire ça avec un tout petit
drone. Non,
non, on le fait mais le drone le petit
drone il ne reste pas assez longtemps en
l'air. Il va rester un quart d'heure,
une demi-heure, ça dépend des modèles,
de l'ordre, de l'heure. Mais les champs
de vigne, ils sont immenses. Vous savez,
si vous allez duas, vous avez des
kilomètres. Et il faut en fait pouvoir
rester longtemps en l'air, se balader
systématiquement, je dirais
photographier, traiter les images et
détecter l'endroit où la flavisscence de
naît. Et à ce moment-là envoyer soit un
robot, soit une personne pour couper le
pied qui est malade. Et ça, ça se fait
avec une machine comme ça très
facilement.
On a vu
un exemple de travail aérien, mais il y
en a bien d'autres. On a vu Facebook
développer euh des drones de
télécommunication pour fournir de
l'internet un peu partout dans le monde.
Est-ce que le dirigeable ce serait une
solution ?
Oui, bien sûr, mais les clients
d'Internet en général veulent un service
7 jours sur 7 24h sur 24. Et du fait de
la limite d'emploi d'un dirigeable avec
le vent, on ne pourra pas assurer avec
une seule machine un service continu.
Alors, on peut réfléchir et on y
réfléchit à des solutions où il y aurait
une flotte de dirigeable qui assurerait
ce service et si le vient devint fort et
bien le dirigeable en question va
dériver mais un autre prendra sa place.
C'est ce qui se passe avec les
satellites. Vous savez, les satellites,
ils tournent autour de la Terre, votre
GPS là, bah c'est en fait, c'est une
flotte de satellite qui rend le service.
Vous pouvez pas imposer à un satellite
basse altitude de rester en point fixe.
En fait, il se relay et on peut imaginer
la même chose. Google d'ailleurs a
commencé à faire ça avec le projet
Google Loon, hein. Il a mis en place
notamment à Porteau, ça a été
spectaculaire après une catastrophe qui
avait détruit toutes les liaisons par
câble. Je sais pas exactement ce qui
s'est passé, mais Google a mis en
service des ballons, des ballons qui ont
assuré le relais. si vous voulez des
transmissions le temps qu'on répare
hein. Mais c'était des ballons qui
dérivaient, c'est-à-dire que en fait il
avait il avait besoin aussi d'une flotte
de ballon pour assurer le service en
continu.
Alors là une question dont la réponse
est déjà dans le titre. Ces machines
peuvent donc également photographier,
surveiller la population. Point
d'interrogation.
Ah oui.
Est-ce que vous avez été contacté par
l'armée, par la police ?
Tout le monde en parle.
Tout le monde en parle. Qu'est-ce que ça
dit ?
C'est pas mon problème. Moi, j'offre une
plateforme pass à l'utilisateur, il fait
ce qu'il a envie de faire.
Nous, on n pas de jugement là-dessus.
S'il y a un client qui a besoin de ça,
nous on lui offre la machine. C'est pas
à moi de juger si vous voulez de l'usage
qui est fait hein. C'est au pouvoir
public, c'est c'est à la société, c'est
pas à moi. Nous, on nous demande une
machine, nous on fait la machine dont le
client a besoin.
Euh, autre question d'Internet qui euh
Ne pensez-vous pas qu'un appareil comme
le vôtre, entre parenthèses, qui ne
dépense pas très peu d'énergie, puisse
être vu de d'un mauvais œil par des
puissantes compagnies organisation point
d'interrogation, subissez-vous des
pressions ?
[Musique]
communauté.
Il existe il existe
dans cette société économique des
lobbyes. Il existe des lobbyes.
Les lobby sont à l'œuvre.
Après ça, bon, je dirais c'est
essentiellement ce que la société dans
son ensemble attend qui finira par
émerger.
Les lobby pourront freiner. On sait
connaî toute l'histoire des avancées
techniques. Une innovation de rupture
est toujours mal perçu par ceux qui
détiennent les grandes parts de marché
avec la technologie qui est dépassée
toujours. Bon, donc il y a des réactions
humaines, ils vont freiner, ils vont
s'opposer avec tous les moyens à leur
disposition bien sûr, mais au bout du
compte, l'innovation de rupture, elle
finit toujours par passer. Bon, si on
vous voit avoir un accident de voiture
suspect ou une chute malencontreuse, on
s'inquiète ou on s'inquiète pas ?
Là, il y aura une enquête. On peut
s'inquiéter. Il y aura une enquête. Je
je ne pense pas sérieusement, bon à part
ce qu'on voit dans les bandes dessiné
Tintin et autres, je ne Non, je ne pense
pas sérieusement qu'on en arrive là.
Bon, le monde le monde est en progrès
technologique permanent. Bon, c'est pas
pour autant que la criminalité, je
dirais augmente entre les gens qui sont
en place sur le marché envers ceux qui
apportent des solutions techniques.
Confiant.
Confiant, réaliste. Réaliste. Réaliste.
Non, je
Est-ce que vous avez pensé à faire un
crowfunding digne de ce nom sur internet
?
On a pensé On a pensé absolument
faire appel à la communauté voir
international.
On a pensé on a pensé
ce qu'on cherche quand même en premier
en ce moment, c'est si vous voulez une
caution technique des du pôle de
compétitivité qui est en charge de ces
projets, c'est-à-dire pour ce qui nous
concerne le pôle ASTEC dans la région
parisienne. On est on est en discussion
avec eux, on va être labellisé, ça c'est
clair. Ils vont labelliser ce projet et
c'est un passeport important si vous
voulez d'avoir cette ce label hein pour
aller n'importe où pour demander des
fonds que ce soit des investisseurs
privés, des investisseurs étatiques ou
le crowdfunding.
On a décidé de faire des choses dans cet
ordre hein parce que je pense qu'on a
beaucoup plus de chance de de réussir.
Les les gens les gens sont prêts à
investir, c'est clair, mais quand ils
comprennent pas le probl
les gens les Français
les gens en général les Français
je peut-être
peut-être moins que certains étrangers
le Fran
J'en arrive à mon autre question. Est-ce
que vous avez été un petit peu
d'autres États vous ont fait un petit
peu vous ont passé la main dans le dos
un petit peu ?
Non non, les États ne passent pas la
main dans le dos.
Est-ce que vous êtes un entrepreneur
patriotique ? Ah ben je suis
patriotique. Oui. Euh bien évidemment
jusqu'à une certaine limite. Si s'il y
avait un investisseur étranger qui
souhaite investir dans ce projet, on le
ferait. On le ferait. Mais les vous
savez les dirigeables, c'est quand même
c'est enthousiasmant. Ça fait tellement
longtemps qu'on cherche. Mais d'un autre
côté les gens se posent des questions.
Mais bon dieu, pourquoi est-ce que ça
marche toujours pas ? Donc les porteurs
de projet qui arrivent, bon on les
regarde quand même avec
ce stress de l'édimbourg qui flambe.
On peut avoir des doutes, hein. Il y a
il y a eu tellement de projets qui ont
été financés puis finalement qui se sont
pas vendus que quand on arrive après les
autres, il y a on va dire au départ un
certain scepticisme. Donc c'est pour ça
qu'il nous faut vouz une caution
technique d'un organisme extérieur
compétent. Et là, je pense que on va
arriver à trouver les les financeurs.
Mais si c'est des financeurs étrangers,
on n pas du tout pas du tout opposé. Au
contraire, hein.
Est-ce que Est-ce que vous avez fait un
peu la tournée des popotes avec le
président avec la Frenchtech ou des
choses comme ça ? Est-ce que vous avez
reçu des prix pour votre projet ?
Ah oui oui oui, on a été primé en au
salon du Bourger. C'était en ça devait
être en 2011. Après après que ce
démonstrateur là dont on a parlé, modèle
réduit et volé, on a reçu le prix
d'innovation technologique du salon du
bourger. Oui, c'est vrai, on l'a reçu.
Alors, c'est le ministre qui nous a
remis ça. Bertrand Picard était là,
c'était Nathalie aussi commisé, ils nous
ont remis ça devant tous les
journalistes. C'était un moment chaud en
effet. Bon et mais ceci ne suffit pas
pourvaincre des investisseurs. Ça ne
suffit pas.
Question d'Internet. Au niveau
écologique et pour l'écosystème, peut-il
y avoir des problèmes pour les oiseaux ?
Pollution visuelle, point
d'interrogation.
Alors les si
par exemple on se prend on se prend une
cigogne dans la toile, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Alors c'est pas exclu hein. Les corbeaux
ont les corneilles ont la mauvaise idée
effectivement de donner des coups de bec
dans tous les objets qui se trouvent par
là. Ça, on le sait. Bon, dans notre cas,
ça n'a auc aucun inconvénient parce
qu'en fait, nous avons une double peau.
Il y a une caraine extérieure qui est
faite en toile de bateau, en toile de
spinaker, hein. Et euh à l'intérieur,
nous avons les sacs d'hélium mais en
retrait à 70 cm à peu près hein, de la
carine extérieure, nous avons les sacs
d'hélium. Si si un oiseau donne un coup
de bec dans le tissu, bah, il va faire
un trou. Mais ça ça n'aura pas plus de
conséquences. le la portabilité de de du
gaz reste la même. Donc c'est là-dessus,
on alors on réparera les ça se répare
quand on sera revenu à la base, ben on
verra qu'il y a un trou. On répara ça se
répare toutes ces chosesl.
Alors une question qui va peut-être vous
paraître sa grenu. Imaginez-vous que un
terroriste mette un coup de fusil
dedans. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Ça fuit
? Ça fait pchit.
Ça va fuir mais pas beaucoup.
Pas beaucoup.
Ça dépend avec quelle arme il tire.
Évidemment,
c'est sûr que s'il tire au bazooka,
c'est
ça fait un trop gros. Mais l'appareil
continue à voler quand même. L'appareil
continue à voler. Il y a eu des cas
comme ça où il y a eu des trous.
On raconte cette histoire, elle est Je
vais vous la vous la dire, c'est le KNÈ
fait des ballons sondes. Il fait des
ballons sondes et les ballons sonde, si
vous voulez, on les contrôle au moins en
montée et en descente et puis quand on a
envie de redescendre, ben on fait
quelque chose et le ballon se dégonfle
et il redescend. Bon, il est arrivé il y
a quelques années, pardonnez-moi, je me
souviens plus quelle année, que un
ballon sonde soit tout d'un coup en
perte de contrôle depuis le sol. Donc le
ballon restait en l'air, on pouvait pas
le faire un rosel. Non, c'est ça. C'est
un Roswell. Ah, je sais pas. Bon, bon,
donc c'était un peu embêtant parce que
quand le ballon est assez haut, si vous
voulez, bon, s'il y a des avions qui
passe par là, bon, c'est quand même
embêtant quoi. Bon, alors le Kness qui
était l'opérateur a immédiatement
prévenu les autorités en disant
"Écoutez, il y a un ballon là qu'on
contrôle plus, il est à 3000 m et puis
il est là, il dérive." Bon, alors on a
demandé à la à l'armée d'aller régler le
problème et de tirer dessus. Donc les
virages ont décollé, ils ont tiré au
canon de 30 sur le truc. Ah oui, mais le
truc il est pas descendu, il a continué,
il a continué. Puis euh force était
constaté qu'il voulait pas descendre et
puis il a continué à dériver. Il est
allé jusqu'en Italie. D'ailleurs, on a
prévenu les Italiens le disant dit non,
il y a un ballon qui arrive chez vous
là. Vous savez, on narrive pas. Oh petit
crétin, les Français, on va s'en
occuper. Ils ont fait décoller la
chasse. Boum boum boum. Ah ben oui, le
ballon est toujours pas descendu. Il a
quand même volé 3 jours. Il est rentré
d'Italie en France et il a terminé en
Angleterre. Donc vous voyez, c'est
difficile d'abattre un ballon sonde ou
un dirigeable de ce type là sans
pression parce qu' il marche sans
pression dedans. Il y a pas de pression
pour le faire voler et du coup vous
tirez, vous faites des trous dans les
sacs mais le gaz il a pas envie de
sortir, il sort très peu. Donc en fait
il reste en l'air. Donc le terrorisme
oui théoriquement mais je vais vous dire
les terroristes aujourd'hui, ils ont
bien mieux à faire. S'ils veulent
vraiment faire du dégât, ils ont bien
mieux à faire. On va on va pas leur
donner d'idée.
Non, ils en ont déjà bien et on peut
faire des choses plus faciles.
Le plafond maximum opérationnel,
bah c'est ce que veut le client.
C'est-à-dire que s'il veut monter par
exemple à 6000 m, on va concevoir une
machine hein qui va avoir un volume plus
grand, hein, parce que quand on monte
haut, la pression diminue, donc le gaz
s'expand. Donc il faut un volume
d'expansion plus grand, c'est possible
mais la machine est plus grosse donc
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué de
tenir le devis de poids. Admettons
admettons, on gagne au lotu où on fait
un creux de fending géant et et je
souhaiterais voir la courbure de la
terre.
Ah là il faudrait monter assez haut, il
faudrait monter à 20 km, c'est possible.
On peut on pourrait avec une machine
spéciale, j'ai déjà fait une proposition
d'ailleurs à Marc Alban qu'il me l'a
demandé, une proposition pour monter,
faire du tourisme spatial. C'est c'est
ce qu'on appelle du tourisme spatial
pour monter à 20 km et on verrait là le
ciel noir et un peu la courbure et tout
ça, c'est possible mais c'est pas le
meilleur moyen de monter à 20 km. C'est
pas le meilleur moyen. Ils vont mieux y
aller en avion
ou avec un un ballon plus souple, moins
dirigeable. Mais ça pourrait être un
ballon sonde effectivement. Oui, on
pourrait. Oui, bien sûr. Ça s'est fait
d'ailleurs. Ça c'est fait.
Qu'est-ce qu'on vous pose comme question
quand il y a un investisseur devant vous
? Qu'est-ce qu'il vous pose comme
question ?
Alors,
bizarrement bizarrement
comme il comprend pas la technique, il
comprend pas, il peut pas avoir de
jugement sur la technique donc il est un
petit peu inquiet. Donc il va poser des
questions dans les domaines où il a une
certaine compétence. Et ces domaines, ça
va être le plus souvent
est-ce que vous allez construire une
usine ? Comment vous allez faire pour
construire votre dirigeable ? Vous allez
construire une usine, vous allez
embaucher du monde, vous allez acheter
des machines, il va poser des questions
dans ce domaine parce que il va pouvoir
comprendre les réponses. Bon, alors là,
on lui explique que on en est pas là,
que ce qu'on veut faire, c'est un
démonstrateur pour que tout le monde
voit, constate que tout ce qu'on
prévoit, tout ce qu'on sait qui va se
passer, on le c'est vérifié. Et là,
quand cette machine volera, marchera, là
on est certain que les investisseurs
auront plus confiance et qu'ils
investiront. Au niveau de l'emploi par
exemple.
Alors oui oui au niveau de l'emploi, on
a fait des projections bien évidemment.
Euh si on s'en tient au marché du
tourisme euh qui est le premier marché
qu'on vise, hein, c'est vraiment un
véritable marché. Euh les perspectives
euh à 10 ans, si vous voulez pour faire
du tourisme, c'est 1000 machines de ce
genre, hein. C'est très clair que il y
aurait au moins ce marché là. Et ça
c'est pour le monde. Et en France, si on
regarde le nombre de sites qui seraient
de toute évidence euh intéressé à
accueillir ce genre de machine, il y en
a au moins une cinquantaine. Ben vous
prenez le Mont Saint-Michel, vous prenez
les plages du débarquement, vous savez
les plages du débarquement, on arrive,
c'est c'est très émouvant, on voit le
cimetière, il y a le a le sanctuaire,
tout ça. Alors, on vous explique tout ce
qui s'est passé, mais on voit pas la
plage. On est là dans la campagne et on
voit rien. Si on pouvait s'élever,
survoler tout ça, aller voir les
falaises où les gars se sont fait
abattre, les plages et ça, ça serait
magnifique. C'est un site qui
manifestement
appelle à à être visité par des
dirigeables. Il y a une cinquantaine, au
moins une cinquantaine de sites en
France, si c'est pas plus, si vous
voulez, qui sont susceptibles vraiment
d'accueillir ce genre de dirigeable. Et
pour exploiter tout ça, pour exploiter
ça, c'est des milliers de personnes
qu'il faudrait. des milliers de
personnes, c'est des emplois, des
emplois très compétents où il faut
former les gens, des pilotes, des
techniciens, des choses comme ça. C'est
c'est vraiment si vous voulez un
gisement de création d'emploi
extrêmement intéressant en France et
dans le reste du monde parce que le
nombre de sites
où on pourrait faire du tourisème aérien
et
je vous coupe,
il y aura-t-il une application
publicitaire ? Est-ce qu'on vaevoir ce
ballon avec le
Il y a un espace publicitaire évidemment
puisqu'il y a une grande surface. Donc
si vous vous promenez par exemple autour
du Mont-Sa Michel, alors les gens
forcément regarderont dès que vous voyez
une machine volée, tout le monde la
regarde même si on est blasé, on la
regarde. Bon celle-là en particulier,
vous rendez compte un dirigeable à 100 m
là qui passe autour du Mont
Saint-Michel, tout le monde la regarde.
Ah c'est pas moche du tout. C'est très
beau.
Non, mais un dirigeable, oui, mais un
dirigeable avec marqué euh
Ah bah après ça, c'est une question de
politique. Il y a un espace publicitaire
qu'on peut vendre ou ne pas vendre. Si
on le vend effectivement, si c'est les
parfums Paco Raban, bah c'est les
parfums PacoRaban.
On va pas citer de marque.
Pardon ?
Ah non, je cite pas de marque mais tout
est possible.
Ou un site internet. Bon,
est-ce que vous voyez un dirigeable
autour du Mont Saint-Michel avec marqué
Youorn dessus ?
Moi je suis je suis Non mais c'est
l'exploitant qui décidera, si vous
voulez, c'est pas le constructeur qui
décide de ça, c'est l'exploitant.
L'exploitant fait son business plan avec
de la publicité ou sans publicité et
après ça c'est lui qui gère. Nous, on
fait la plateforme, on on conçoit, on
fabrique, on met à disposition, on met
en service la plateforme.
On va revenir à vous l'entrepreneur.
Comment ça se passe dans votre tête ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans votre tête
quand on pense dirigeable ? Moi, ça fait
50 ans plus que ça, même 60 ans que j'y
pense. Je le vois voler ce dirigeable.
Je le vois. Je le vois voler et j'espère
bien qu'on on va y arriver. Je suis plus
seul maintenant. Il y a tas de gens qui
pensent aussi qu'on va y arriver.
C'est c'est le projet d'une vie, hein.
C'est beau.
Ah oui, c'est beau. Je serais très
content de de voir ça avant de avant de
La famille vous soutient à fond, vos
copains ?
Ma femme ma femme soutient énormément.
Toujours derrière un grand homme, il y a
toujours une grande femme. Non, c'est
ça.
Je sais pas si c'est une grande femme.
Passe le bonjour d'ailleurs.
Elle me soutient beaucoup, on peut le
dire. Alix me soutient énormément. C'est
c'est très important. Mes salariés
aussi. D'ailleurs, dans notre société,
les salariés sont tous actionnaires,
hein. C'est le principe. J'ai environ 25
actionnaires, des amis pour l'essentiel
qui ont apporté de l'argent pour qu'on
puisse en être là aujourd'hui.
Je suis très entouré
mais financièrement ça suffit pas si
vous voulez pour aller au bout de ce
projet. Il faut que des investisseurs
privés ou publics rentrent dans le
projet.
Est-ce que vous avez un message pour
l'internet ?
Pour l'internet,
la communauté, est-ce que
Bah écoutez, euh
si ce projet vous plaît,
rentrez dans le projet, investissez même
si c'est modeste, investissez parce
qu'on sera toujours content. On va vous
poser la la dernière question notre
notre format qui est laisser un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. C'est une
question qu'on pose à tout le monde.
Ah !
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations en tant
qu'entrepreneur, inventeur ?
J'ai plusieurs conseils, mais le le
conseil que je donnerai aux jeunes euh
sur internet ou quand j'en reçois parce
que j'en reçois beaucoup qui sont
intéressés par faire des stages,
je leur dis euh choisissez un job qui
d'abord vous plaît et deuxièmement
choisissez une entreprise avec lequel
vous avez le fit et notamment
vous avez le
le fit. Il faut avoir le fit avec
l'équipe, il faut avoir le fit avec son
patron.
C'est la clé de tout. Si vous avez le
fit avec l'équipe, si vous êtes
intéressé par le sujet, vous ferez des
choses formidable. Formidable.
Philippe Tixier, merci.
C'était un plaisir.
Cut.
[Musique]